[NO AUDIO]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANAND IYER: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Anand
Iyer, and today I
will be talking about Kubeflow
Pipelines, an exciting new set
of features that we have added
to the popular open source
project Kubeflow.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
So let's get started.
First, some
introductions real quick.
As I mentioned, my
name is Anand Iyer,
and I am a product manager
in the Cloud AI platform
team within Google Cloud.
The Cloud AI platform provides
the set of tools and services
you need to build custom machine
learning applications that
entail building, training,
and deploying your own custom
machine learning models.
We're also very
fortunate to have
Andreas Rodriguez
as my co-presenter,
and he will be talking about how
Intel, our very close partner,
has leveraged Kubeflow
Pipelines to build components
for their OpenVINO toolkit.
So first, let me present the
high level agenda of the talk.
First, I'll present
the motivations
behind the various
tools and services
that we're building as part
of the Cloud AI platform
and provide an overview of the
approach that we're taking.
Next, we will do a deeper dive
into the specific problems
that inspired the Kubeflow
Pipelines initiative.
After that, we'll get into the
meat of the presentation, which
is where I'll give you a
demo of Kubeflow Pipelines
and also talk about
under-the-hood technical
details pertaining to
Kubeflow Pipelines.
And after that, I will
hand it over to Andreas
to talk about how Intel has
leveraged Kubeflow Pipelines
to build components for
their OpenVINO toolkit.
So first, what's our motivation?
What are we trying to solve as
part of the Cloud AI platform?
The key problem that
we're trying to address
is the fact that
building and deploying
real-life ML applications
is harder and costlier
than it needs to be.
And that is because
of lack of tooling
that covers the end-to-end
machine learning life cycle,
the end-to-end life cycle for
development and deployment
of custom machine
learning applications.
And that is the key problem
that we're trying to solve.
Now the next couple
of slides will
be a little bit of
repetition for folks that
attended the previous webinar.
But nevertheless, I will cover
this content again real quick
for those that may watch this
presentation later on YouTube.
When we spoke to
customers, there
were three high
level themes that
emerged as persistent problems
that hold customers back
from building successful
machine learning applications.
The first problem was
that of deployment.
Today's infrastructure is
brittle and opinionated,
and the environments change
when you go from your laptop
to the cluster.
And also in today's world,
hybrid is a reality.
The other big problem
is that of talent.
It's just really hard to find
machine learning experts.
And if every machine
learning application
needs a team of
experts, well that
is going to be a
severe bottleneck
for the successful deployment
of machine learning.
Then the last piece
was collaboration.
Everyone is
reinventing the wheel
and re-implementing components,
whereas the ideal state
of the world is where different
teams collaborate and reuse
assets that they're building.
These three problems
at a high level
are the problems
we want to tackle.
And the three pillars
towards our solution
are Kubeflow, reusable
pipelines, and AI Hub.
Kubeflow is a popular
open source project,
and Kubeflow aims to simplify
the end-to-end machine learning
life cycle.
It provides a set of
services and libraries
that are seamlessly
integrated, that address
the needs of the various
stages of a machine learning
application.
Kubeflow is a
collection of services
that runs on the Kubernetes
execution engine.
And we chose Kubernetes because
Kubernetes is effectively
the de facto for deploying
applications that
leverage a cluster of machines.
So by leveraging
Kubernetes, we are
able to effectively
provide a hybrid solution,
because Kubernetes is
the de facto platform
on premise as well as
on multiple clouds.
Kubeflow enables customers
to move their applications
from on premise to the
clouds and so forth.
A couple more key
aspects of Kubeflow,
it is an open
source library that
supports multiple machine
learning frameworks.
It is not limited to TensorFlow.
It supports scikit-learn,
XGBoost, Python,
and multiple other frameworks.
And because it's open source,
we work with the community
to assimilate newer frameworks
that become popular.
One more key thing to
highlight is the fact that,
while Kubeflow is open source,
if you deploy Kubeflow on GCP--
particularly on Google's
Kubernetes Engine GKE--
we have built some
integrations that
make it very seamless
to deploy Kubeflow.
And also, for the most
popular Kubeflow services,
you can leverage fully managed
equivalents on Google Cloud.
So you don't always have to
manage your infrastructure.
The other aspect is
reusable pipelines.
And over here, the Lego
analogy is very apt.
We want to get to a world where
components and pipelines built
by others can
seamlessly be reused.
We don't want people to
reinvent the wheel all the time.
And this is
particularly important
because in today's world, every
machine learning application
is considered to be a
bespoke application.
So whenever someone's
building a custom machine
learning application,
the first thing they need
is a data scientist or a
machine learning engineer
that is focused on
that application
and will build a
bespoke solution.
But that is not always the case.
Often, what you need
to do is actually look
at other successful
applications,
and reuse the stuff
they've built,
and tweak the components
that you need to tweak.
And that is what
we want to enable.
And then the third
aspect is the AI Hub.
You can think it as a one stop
shop, or a one stop catalog,
for machine learning content.
And I use the word
content because we
will have multiple
different types of assets.
We will clearly have pipelines
built with Kubeflow Pipelines
infrastructure.
We'll also have
usable components
that you can leverage as a
part of Kubeflow Pipelines.
But we'll also have other
assets like pre train models,
or embeddings, or
even just notebooks
where a particular
model is being trained.
So long story short, AI Hub
becomes your one stop shop
to find assets
that you can either
reuse, or use as inspiration
to build your own custom
applications.
All right.
So with that, now
let's do a deeper dive
into the specific
problems that inspired
the Kubeflow Pipelines project.
So the key premise here is
the fact that in addition
to the actual machine learning--
What I mean by the
actual ML, we're
talking about the code
that trains the model
or does influence
with the model.
In addition to that, there
are multiple other phases
that you actually have
to implement and manage
for a successful end-to-end
machine learning application.
There's data integration,
data collection,
feature engineering, data
validation, model deployment,
and then tooling to capture
metrics and orchestrate
all these pieces together.
And that can often
get non-trivial.
And that is a core problem
that we want to solve.
Let me also present a
few customer quotes that
will make things more tangible.
One customer that we spoke to
said that they don't really
have an ML workflow today.
What they've basically
done is taken workflows
that they've used for
general software development
and applied that in the
machine learning context.
But that lacks the
things that ML needs,
and that is one problem
we want to solve.
The other problem is
we spoke to customers
where they don't retrain their
models on a frequent basis,
despite the fact that model
freshness was actually
important for their business.
And part of the reason they
don't retrain models as often
is because the retraining
process was very manual.
But we wanted to
solve that problem
and make it very
easy for customers
to set up constant or retraining
pipelines that can be scheduled
to run on a periodic basis
so that they can get newer,
updated models more easily.
A third customer
that we spoke to
basically said ML
experimentation
is like the Wild West today.
Everyone is using ad-hoc tools.
There is no standardization.
It's very hard to go
back and understand
what led to the production
of a particular model.
It's hard to know what
techniques have been tried,
what experiments have been
run, and so on and so forth.
And we want to solve that.
We want to make it
easy for you to have
one place where you can track
all the experiments that
were done.
So with that, let me dive
into the demo section
where we cover pertinent aspects
of the Kubeflow Pipelines
project.
Before we dive in, I want to
talk about the three feature
buckets into which the
capabilities of Kubeflow
Pipelines can be classified.
The three buckets
are machine learning
workflow orchestration, rapid
reliable experimentation,
and sharing, reuse,
and composability.
So the Kubeflow Pipelines
project, at a very high level,
is solving problems that fall
under these three buckets.
So first, let me talk about
ML workflow orchestration.
Because we've been talking about
multi-step machine learning
pipelines, let me make
things more concrete by first
presenting a visual
depiction of a pipeline that
has been executed on the
Kubeflow Pipelines framework.
So this is the Kubeflow
Pipelines console
depicting an actual
pipeline that was executed.
Now in this particular
case, this pipeline
starts with a validation
step where incoming data
is analyzed to make sure that
there are no data quality
issues.
After that, there is
a pre-processing step,
followed by a training step.
And then the model that's
produced in the training step,
in one scenario, is used
for doing prediction
on offline data.
In another scenario,
the same model
is being deployed to
a serving endpoint.
And then, there's
a third process
where the model is being
used to do deeper analysis
on the validation data set.
Now, this is just an
illustrative pipeline.
And you can build multiple
different configurations
of pipelines with
this framework.
A few key things to
highlight here are,
in addition to the visual
depiction of the stages
of the pipeline-- which makes
it very easy for you to come
in and understand what
that pipeline is doing--
you actually get a whole set
of rich information required
to understand in sufficient
detail what was happening when
this pipeline was executed.
So you can see all the
configuration parameters
and all the input
parameters that
were provided to the pipeline.
For each step of
the pipeline, you
can drill deep and
select a particular step,
and then see the
inputs and outputs
of that individual step.
So the inputs that
were provided,
what were the outputs
that were produced.
You can also look at
logs that were produced,
so that you can debug
things when they fail or get
a deeper understanding
of what happened
when that step was run.
What is particularly
compelling is certain steps
will produce interesting
data that can be visualized.
So for example, if
you're doing analysis--
and in this particular
case, the analysis step
was implemented using the
TensorFlow Model Analysis
component that's part
of the TFX library.
It produces a rich
set of artifacts
that can be visualized with
this slice and dice UI.
And the visualization
of the metrics
is embedded right
here in the console.
So for the metrics
that are produced,
you can visualize
them right here.
So in this particular
case, you can
do slicing and dicing of the
metrics produced by that model.
Let's take another example.
If I go to the
prediction step, I
can visualize the output,
which is tabular output where
each offline data set and the
corresponding score assigned
to it can be visualized.
And if I go to the
training step, for example,
I can, by the click of a button,
open the TensorBoard instance,
where I can now get a deeper
understanding of what happened
when that model was trained.
So long story short, a lot
of rich visual information
is readily available
at your fingertips
so that you can
understand what happened
when a pipeline was done.
So let me go back and cover
some pertinent details
about what
constitutes a pipeline
and exactly what
are the pieces that
define a Kubeflow Pipeline.
In its simplest form,
a Kubeflow Pipeline
is a set of containerized
machine learning tasks.
The reason we
chose containers is
because containers
are the industry
standard for portability,
repeatability,
and encapsulation.
And of course, we want you to go
from prototyping to production
as quickly as possible,
and thus containerizing
your steps enables that.
We also wanted repeatability
and reliability,
and again, containers are the
industry standard solution
for that.
And that's why we did
not want to reinvent that
and re-leverage containers.
But that being said, even
though each step of the pipeline
is a containerized task,
that doesn't mean it
has to run on a single node.
A given task can run
in distributed fashion.
It can be a model that's
trained in distributed fashion.
It can be an Apache Spark step
which is doing distributed data
processing or an Apache Beam
step that's doing distributed
data processing.
The key thing I
want to highlight
is even though a given
step is encapsulated
as a container,
when it's actually
deployed on the
Kubernetes cluster,
it can run on
multiple worker nodes.
So it can run in
distributed fashion.
Another thing worth
highlighting is
the different steps
of the pipeline
can use different hardware.
So you can have the training
step, which needs GPUs,
and then the pre processing
steps probably just
need a high memory machine
for distributed processing.
But the key thing is,
different steps of the pipeline
can leverage different
forms of hardware.
And it's very easy
for you to specify
what hardware is required.
A third thing I
want to highlight
is the fact that even though
a step of the pipeline
is executed as a container,
these containerized steps
can easily invoke Cloud
native services that
are running elsewhere.
So for example, you can
have a containerized step
that is calling Cloud
Machine Learning APIs.
Or, you can have a containerized
step that is calling out
to other fully managed services
like BigQuery, or Cloud Machine
Learning Engine, or Dataflow.
So that's a core part of
what a Kubeflow Pipeline is.
It's a set of containers that
encapsulate machine learning
tasks.
The other part of it is
specifying the higher level
workflow, specifying
the sequence in which
these tasks need to be run.
And to do that, we provide
a very intuitive Python
SDK that I'll demo
in a few seconds.
Then the third piece that
constitutes a pipeline
are the set of parameters
that the user has to pass in.
So when we say a
Kubeflow Pipeline,
that essentially
constitutes the containers
for the individual steps,
the higher level workflow
definition, and the parameters
that the user has to pass in.
So with that, let's go back and
take a look at how a Kubeflow
Pipeline is authored.
So as I mentioned, we provided
a very intuitive Python SDK.
And time and again when
we spoke to our customers,
everyone said Python
is their lingua franca.
So essentially, we
decided to provide
a very Python-ic SDK that will
feel intuitive to our audience.
And this Python SDK can, for
example, be invoked from an IDE
or even from a notebook.
And because authoring
machine learning components
from notebooks is as
popular these days,
I'll actually demo usage of
the Kubeflow Pipelines SDK
from a notebook.
So when it comes to
altering a pipeline,
there are two distinct phases.
One is defining the
higher level workflow,
and then the other is defining
the individual components.
And first, let me start with
the higher level workflow.
And what I mean by the
high level workflow
is the definition of the
sequence in which these steps
need to be executed.
So to define the workflow,
essentially authoring
the workflow is as intuitive
as authoring a Python function.
You essentially define
a Python function that
encapsulates your workflow.
And then you annotate that
with a function decorator
that essentially signifies that
this is a Kubeflow Pipeline
definition.
For your function, you
will provide arguments,
which are essentially
the inputs that an end
user needs to provide
while running the pipeline.
The arguments can
be annotated so
that you can specify a
name for each argument
and also specify
a default value.
And we'll come back to why that
is very useful and significant.
So long story short, you
define a Python function.
You specify arguments.
These are the inputs
to the function.
And then you start specifying
the different steps
of the pipeline and how
they're hooked together.
Each step of the pipeline is
invoked like a Python function.
At this point, you're
wondering, wait a minute.
Each step of the pipeline
is a containerized step.
How did it become
a Python function?
Just hold on to that
thought, and I'll answer
that question in a few minutes.
But for now, assume that
each step of the pipeline
is encapsulated as
a Python function.
So to specify the
workflow, it's as
easy as calling the
corresponding function,
providing the inputs that
that function requires.
And then the sequence in
which the different steps
need to be executed is specified
by connecting the output of one
function and providing
that as the input
to a downstream function.
So in this particular case,
the first step of the pipeline
produces some output, which
is pre processed output.
And then the pre processed
output is provided as input
to the training step.
And that's how you specify
the sequence in which
the steps need to be run.
So that was specifying the
workflow orchestration.
Before we move on,
I should mention
that after you've
defined this function,
the SDK gives you
simple operations where
you can compile this
higher level workflow
definition into a tar.gz
file that can be uploaded
to the pipelines back end.
Or, you can also just
use our client API
to submit the pipeline to the
Kubeflow Pipelines back end.
And once it's uploaded
to the pipeline system,
any user can come in, pick
that pipeline, and execute it.
Actually, let me
depict that over here.
So let's say you go in.
You want to create a new
run, so you create a new run
by specifying a pipeline.
And then as soon as you specify
a pipeline, you give it a name.
And then, you actually
have this form
that is automatically populated,
which specifies the inputs
that you need to provide
to this pipeline.
And then this is where the
annotations to the function
arguments were important.
So the annotations specify
the names of each input,
and the annotations also
specify the default values
for these inputs.
So all you had to do was specify
the pipeline as a function,
specify your function
arguments and annotate them,
and that automatically becomes
this easy to consume form
that someone can use when they
want to execute the pipeline.
And this is important
because often,
the author of the
pipeline is not
going to be the one that
executes the pipeline.
In many cases, the author is
going to execute the pipeline,
but we want to get
to a world where
the author of the pipeline
can give a pre-built pipeline
to others to go and execute.
So I can come in and not
know too many details
about how a particular
pipeline works under the hood.
But I can come in and see
what inputs are required,
type them into this form,
and execute the pipeline.
It's as easy as that.
All right, going back
to the notebook here.
Now, let's talk about how the
different steps of the pipeline
are specified.
As I mentioned, each
step of the pipeline
is a containerized step.
So in its most basic
and most flexible form,
all you have to do is--
so let's take this
example here where
I've built a container
that encapsulates
one step of my pipeline.
I can take this
container, and I basically
wrap it with a
Python function where
I invoke this operation
called the ContainerOp.
So this ContainerOp, which is
part of the Kubeflow Pipelines
SDK, takes as
input the container
that encapsulates the step.
And also, it takes as input
the various parameters
that need to be passed
in by the end user.
And this ContainerOp takes
care of invoking that container
and passing it with
corresponding parameters.
Now often, each container has
its own default entry point.
And often by default, that's
the entry point that's executed.
But sometimes, containers can
have multiple different entry
points, and you can
override the entry
point that needs to be
invoked by using a command.
It's called command.
You can specify that
inside the ContainerOp
and then specify
which entry point has
to be used for a container.
So long story short, once you
have encapsulated your pipeline
as a container,
all you have to do
is wrap it with
this ContainerOp.
And this produces, essentially,
a Python function version
of this operation that
you can then use when
you're defining your workflow.
Now at this point, you're
wondering, hey, wait a minute.
Does that mean every
step that I author,
every step of the pipeline needs
to be built as a container?
That is not the case.
I actually wanted to start
with the most flexible method
of defining pipeline
steps, because anything
that can be put in a
container is fair game.
It can be C++ code, R
scripts, and what have you.
But often, you will
not, as an end user,
have to build the
containers yourself.
You can actually go in and
just author steps of a pipeline
as a simple Python function.
And then after you've
authored the function,
annotate that function with
specific function decorators
that help encapsulate
that function
as a step of the pipeline.
And when you specify
the function decorators,
all you have to do is
specify a base Docker
image that is used to package
that step of the pipeline.
Often, you can get base Docker
images by going to Docker Hub.
For example, if you're
training a TensorFlow pipeline,
the TensorFlow community
provides a bunch
of pre-built Docker
containers that
are available on Docker Hub with
various versions of TensorFlow
and common utilities.
And you can just simply
reuse those containers.
Or if you're working in
a large organization,
you may have your
internal Docker Hub.
But in many cases, a
pre-built container
may not have the
various libraries
that you specifically need.
And again, we have you
covered over there.
So all you have to do is
use this notebook magic
that we have provided, where
you specify the base container
that you want to use.
So in this particular case, I'm
going to use a TensorFlow base
container.
And then after that, simply PIP
install the other dependencies
that you need.
And of course, folks
that use Python are very
comfortable with PIP install.
So you don't need to know
the details of Docker
or Dockerization.
All you have to do is
use this notebook magic,
specify a base container,
and then specify
the other dependencies that need
to be packaged into that base
container.
And we automatically
produce a container
that you can use as the
step of the pipeline,
and it'll have your
custom dependencies.
So long story short, you don't
have to be an expert in Docker
to author each individual
step of the pipeline.
We give you the
utilities that you
need to simplify the authoring
of the various steps.
All right, so that was authoring
of machine learning pipelines.
Now let's go back and look at
the other key value proposition
of Kubeflow Pipelines,
which is rapid, reliable
experimentation.
And this is important because,
particularly in applied machine
learning, when you're building
machine learning applications,
it's all about trying
many different techniques.
The more techniques
you can try, the higher
your likelihood of success.
And that is what
we want to enable.
We want to make it very easy
for you to simply author
an initial pipeline,
clone that pipeline,
edit it to try some
variant of that pipeline,
and then submit it.
And keep doing this
loop very quickly
so you can try multiple
different variants.
And of course, for each pipeline
that you have submitted,
you can view those pipelines
in the Kubeflow Pipelines
consoles.
So you could have
thousands of executions.
You can go in, and you
can see rich information
about each execution.
What is particularly
compelling is, as I mentioned,
we want to make it easy
for you to try variants
of your pipeline by
simply cloning it, editing
it, and submitting it.
And let me actually demo that.
So take an existing pipeline.
Hit the Clone button.
And that opens up this web
form that you can now tweak.
You can update the
parameters that go in.
And then you can submit that
cloned variant of the pipeline.
And you can do this ad nauseam.
And pretty soon, we'll
actually add capabilities
where you can clone a pipeline,
see a version of the code,
tweak the code, and submit.
So long story short, try
multiple different variants
to see what works best.
Now for each variant
of your pipeline,
you can actually see
rich metrics produced
by that pipeline quickly.
So you can identify the
ones that worked well.
And then you can select, say,
a subset of the pipelines.
Let's just say you want
to do some comparisons.
Because often, when you've
launched multiple variants
of a pipeline, you want to
go in and compare them to see
what was different about them.
So I can select a
subset of pipelines
and hit the Compare Runs button.
And I get this
rich UI where I get
rich information, the metrics,
and config parameters,
and so forth of those
executions, side by side,
so I can easily analyze
them and figure out
what was different
about each execution.
And what is particularly
compelling-- and I
find this feature very
interesting-- if you've
done training where you produce
metrics that can be visualized
by TensorBoard for the various
experiments that you selected,
with one click, you can
open a TensorBoard instance
where all the metrics from
those different experiments
are plotted in the
same sort of plot.
So you can do rich analysis
of your experiments.
And then the last
piece is reusability
of pipelines and components.
So let me quickly depict that.
So let's just say you've
authored a multi-step pipeline.
In this particular case, you
have a six step pipeline.
Not every step of the pipeline
has to be authored by you.
In many cases, you will find
existing components from, say,
the AI Hub that you can reuse
as a part of your pipeline.
Another example is where
you might have an existing
pipeline, and you just want to
swap one step of the pipeline
with a different step.
So let's just say you
have a pipeline that
uses scikit-learn
to do some training.
And then you soon realize
that, in the AI Hub,
there is a TensorFlow based
implementation that might just
work great for your case.
Well fantastic, just simply
swap the training component
of a pipeline.
And now you have a new
variant that you can try.
So that's how Kubeflow
Pipelines helps
you go from prototyping
to production real quick.
And with that, I'd like to
introduce Andreas Rodriguez
to talk about how you can use
OpenVINO to get the most out
of your Kubeflow Pipelines.
[NO AUDIO]
ANDREAS RODRIGUEZ:
Thanks, Anand,
for introducing the
Kubeflow Pipelines.
Before I proceed, I
encourage you to continue
typing your questions.
And there are Google and Intel
engineers answering them.
Intel and Google are partnering
to enhance the Kubeflow
Pipelines.
As a first step, Intel added the
OpenVINO toolkit as containers
to Kubeflow Pipelines.
To start, I want to motivate
the reason for the OpenVINO
toolkit, then give a brief
overview of OpenVINO,
and then share how OpenVINO
can be used with the Kubeflow
Pipelines.
Intel provides a
diversity of hardware
that can be used for
artificial intelligence.
Each one has
different strengths,
such as better throughput,
better latency, or better
power, or better
memory, or better cost,
or better generality, depending
on the specific application.
Intel's AI hardware products
includes the various types
of CPUs for both data center
and client, GPUs, VPUs
or visual processing
units, FPGAs, and NNPs
or neural network
processor accelerators.
Given the hardware
diversity, Intel
develop a unified API
and software toolkit
that can be used for inference
across all the various hardware
products.
This software tool
is known as OpenVINO,
which stands for
open visual inference
and neural net optimization.
OpenVINO has three main
components, the deep learning
deployment tool kit or DLDT,
an OpenCV and Media SDK
used for traditional vision
and video processing,
and a collection of pre
train models and tutorials.
At a high level, OpenVINO
provides a unified programming
model across various hardware,
is optimized for performance
and memory footprint,
is extendable for custom
workloads, provides broad
operating system support,
is self-contained for a simple,
out-of-the-box experience,
and is open source for
the community to enhance
and contribute.
The main component that we
will focus in this presentation
is DLDT, Intel's deep
learning deployment tool kit.
It offers a model optimizer
and an inference engine
for optimal inference across
various Intel hardware
products.
The deep learning deployment
tool kit, or DLDT,
is easy to use and
provides high performance
across Intel's
hardware products.
Before using DLDT, you
first need to train a model.
You can train a
model using one of
the many popular deep
learning frameworks
on your hardware of choice.
If you're training on
Intel Xeon processors,
use the Intel MKL-DNN library
to accelerate your training.
DLDT has two steps.
First, DLDT provides an
optimized intermediate
representation, or IR,
over the model's graph.
This includes optimization,
such as layer fusions
or [INAUDIBLE].
Second, this IR is then consumed
by the inference engine,
optimized across various
hardware products.
On the left in this
slide, you can see a list
of currently supported layers.
Intel continues to
expand this list.
If a given layer is not
currently supported,
documentation is
provided detailing
how users can add new
parameters or layers,
or how to further
optimize existing layers.
A feature of DLDT is
heterogeneous execution,
or the ability to execute a
model across various hardware
products.
In this example,
there is a primitive
of a model not supported
or optimized for FPGA, that
is crucial to execute on a CPU.
Another feature is
asynchronous execution
to hide data transfers.
That is, as one inference
cycle is executed,
OpenVINO fetches the data
for the next inference cycle.
Once you have your optimized
intermediate representation,
using the DLDT
Inference Engine is
as simple as these
five lines of code.
Note that in the third line
of code that's highlighted,
the user can select from
multiple hardware products.
This enables the user to
quickly compare performance
across various hardware
products to determine
which one may be
the most suitable
for a particular model.
Intel has been working
with several customers
to enable them to do AI on
Intel's hardware products.
Here are a few examples
of customers we work with
and their testimonials.
GE, for example,
observed a 14 times
performance improvement
using the OpenVINO toolkit
for their task of inference
across X-ray imagery.
Several other
consumers report up
to two orders of magnitude
performance gains
on Intel Xeon processors,
using Intel's optimizations.
Intel and Google are partnering
to bring the performance
and ease of use of
OpenVINO to the masses
by adding DLDT containers
to the Kubeflow Pipelines.
Let's review the
Kubeflow Pipeline
via a hypothetical example.
Suppose you're a data scientist
at American AI company,
examining X-rays to
detect cancerous cells.
There are various containers
to facilitate your work.
The data ingestion,
data transformation,
and data validation
containers facilitate
reading data, transforming the
data to the expected format,
and validating that the
X-ray data is usable
and properly labeled.
This data is passed to
the trainer container.
The output in this
hypothetical example
is a trained cancer
detection model
that is passed through the
model validation container
to ensure the model is ready
for deployment or serving.
The train model is then used for
serving by your medical company
to examine patients' X-rays.
The DLDT Model Optimizer
takes a train model
and gets an optimized
intermediate representation,
which is passed to
the DLDT Inference
Engine for high performance
across the various hardware
back ends.
Note that not all the
train containers are needed
to use the DLDT containers.
The DLDT Model Optimizer can
use an existing train model.
We have only provided
a high level overview.
We invite you to try
the Kubeflow Pipelines
with OpenVINO containers.
In the links provided, we
offer two simple examples
for each of the DLDT containers
to help you get started.
And you can learn more about
the benefits of OpenVINO
using the link at the bottom.
Stay tuned now for live Q&A.
We will be back in less than a
minute.
[NO AUDIO]
ANAND IYER: Looks like we have
a question from the audience.
What are the advantages
of the OpenVINO toolkit
over other serving solutions?
Andreas, all yours.
ANDREAS RODRIGUEZ:
Yeah thanks, Anand.
OpenVINO's optimized
by Intel for optimal
performance across Intel's
hardware back ends.
However, we're working
to extend these benefits
to other inference engines.
For example, we're working
to more tightly couple
some of the benefits of OpenVINO
with TensorFlow Serving.
So that TensorFlow
Serving can also
have the same or a very
similar performance gains
and ease of use that we
can get with OpenVINO
for Intel's hardware.
ANAND IYER: All right.
Stay tuned now for
the next session.
CETV introducing Cloud TPU Pod,
11.5 petaflop supercomputer
for deep learning.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]